[Música]
[Aplausos]
buen día para comenzar a mí me gustaría
hacerles unas preguntas referente a
méxico cuál creen que sea una de las
principales causas de muerte
bueno muchas veces pensamos en
enfermedades directamente y si son una
de las principales causas pero también
hay otra causa la cual son accidentes de
tráfico esos accidentes de tráfico según
la secretaria de comunicación y
transportes han presentado que alrededor
de cada año se presentan 12.000
defunciones es un número muy elevado
entonces nosotros nos decidimos hacer un
proyecto para disminuir precisamente
estas disfunciones y mejorar la calidad
de vida entonces cuando estudiaba lo que
era el sexto semestre de la universidad
aquí justamente en la salle de
ingeniería biomédica
nosotros hablamos mucho con nuestro
coordinador con nuestros maestros
pidiendo la ayuda para fomentar algún
proyecto queríamos trabajar queríamos
hacer investigaciones y siempre nos
tendían la mano pero nunca se concretaba
nada normalmente quedaban comentarios al
aire hasta que un día ha pasado un
tiempo que estuvimos hablando con el
coordinador nos nos comentó la siguiente
frase esta frase nunca la va a olvidar
muchachos se presentó esta oportunidad
hay una convocatoria sobre un proyecto
investigación y los acabo de inscribir
quien quiere entrar
ya estábamos adentro no había manera de
decir que no pero esto nos llevó a la
idea de pensar en que podríamos decir si
entramos y trabajamos sobre este
proyecto investigamos aprendemos nuevas
cosas y tomamos un poco de experiencia o
simplemente decir no mejor queremos
salir y vivir nuestro semestre
tranquilamente pero pues ya estamos
dentro tampoco no había mucho que decir
entonces era el sueño de todo
universitario un tiempo de entrega y
vamos a tener recursos y vamos a tener
una investigación e iba a tener una
aplicación directamente entonces el
proyecto consistía en ver cuando los
choferes de autobuses precisamente que
transportan personas presentaban muchos
accidentes por fatiga entonces queríamos
detectar esta fatiga saber cómo podíamos
determinar cuando una persona estaba
fatigada y en investigación es que
comenzamos a realizar nunca encontramos
un
determinante de la fatiga al cien por
ciento solamente había factores
esenciales que decían éste puede indicar
algo y esto puede indicar otra cosa
entonces decidimos hacer una
investigación en conjunto todos
comenzamos a trabajar y llegamos a que
había cuatro factores muy importantes la
primera era cuando el chófer iba
manejando la fuerza con la que sostenía
el volante así que decidimos implementar
algunos sensores de presión la segunda
era la frecuencia cardíaca cuando una
persona comienza a quedarse dormida su
frecuencia cardíaca disminuye empieza a
latir más despacio el corazón y empieza
a notarse un cierto cansancio entonces
se decidió hacer una pulsera que me
diera justamente los latidos del corazón
todo esto sin que molestará justamente
al conductor otro de los factores que se
vio era las ondas cerebrales cuando una
persona comienza a estar a perder el
estado de alerta empieza a dar sus ondas
cerebrales empiezan a trabajar de una
manera muy diferente entonces si
nosotros logramos mediar medir todo esto
y vamos a tener un
por muy preciso pero no era suficiente
así que decidimos también agregar una
cámara que estuviera viendo la cuestión
gesticular del conductor ya sea su
postura sus párpados iba cabeceando y se
iba poniendo atención
entonces comenzamos a hacer la
investigación y ya teníamos todo lo que
íbamos a necesitar ahora sólo queda
pendiente dividir lo que era el trabajo
de bolas surgieron las personas diciendo
yo quiero trabajar en esta persona otros
compañeros yo quiero trabajar en este
otro en esta otra parte y así
sucesivamente hasta que quedó a la parte
de gesticular curiosamente la más
difícil de todas y si mis compañeros me
la dejaron a cargo a mí y a otra persona
y cuando les pregunte oigan y por qué me
dije en este aquí me contestan es que es
muy difícil y confiamos en que tú lo vas
a hacer
entonces aquí se surgió otra oportunidad
es decir si voy a trabajar voy a querer
investigar voy a querer
seguir adelante o simplemente decir no
mejor yo me dedico a ayudarles en otras
cosas pero pues el ámbito siempre nos ha
impulsado hacia arriba entonces
decidimos tomarlo
conforme íbamos avanzando avanzando
veíamos a nuestros compañeros que iban
avanzando nosotros íbamos mucho más
lento precisamente porque no es un tema
muy fácil estar midiendo con una cámara
en tiempo real lo que está sucediendo
por suerte lo logramos
logramos interpretar cuando una persona
está poniendo atención al camino cuando
está empezando a quedarse dormido y
cuando está empezando a cabecear este
fue nuestro avance el avance de los
demás compañeros lograron medir con
bastante precisión lo que eran las ondas
cerebrales el pulso cardíaco se logró
medir al cien por ciento y lo que era la
presión es esa quedó a un 75 por ciento
porque no todos los pasajeros los
chóferes perdón manejan de la misma
manera pero si se llegó a tener un
resultado muy fiable al final juntamos
todos estos factores y los unimos en un
solo prototipo el cual consiste en una
diadema para las ondas cerebrales que va
en la oreja una pulsera y una cámara
en lo que es el tablero nada de esto
molesta al conductor también en el
volante está lo que son los sensores
entonces de esta manera lo que en alguna
en algún momento creímos que sólo iba a
ser un proyecto de la universidad un
trabajo una investigación más resultó
que no sino que también se comenzó a
implementar en algunas empresas y se
está se sigue probando el prototipo
entonces esperemos que en algunos años
este prototipo ya sé ya sé finalicé tal
cual y empieza a tener un impacto
realmente en méjico y en disminuir estás
de estas defunciones
muchas gracias
ya
[Música]